hey everyone it's Michael Vos from order
flows.com and this is the orderflows
market analysis for Wednesday July 12th
2017 and wow what a day it was Da Rose
to a record high close um basically
following Janet yellen's Congressional
testimony basically she signaled that
the FED will gradually tighten policy
and gradually unwind its massive balance
sheet and in a nutshell saying she
expressed that um the FED will gradually
raise interest rates of course that will
depend on her still being there I think
there was a question asking if uh she's
going to give another testimony she'll
be around next year she said she doesn't
know um we'll wait and see what uh what
that's going to happen
and you know her her doish tone sort of
alleviates some of the concerns over the
recent dip in inflation um but coming
into this uh testimony you know I think
people were a bit worried that she's
going to be a little bit hawkish and she
wasn't basically she said exactly what
the market expected and and the market
was happy with it you know that's that's
why we rallied so um before we jump in
you brief disclaimer this presentation
is for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
contractor or make any other type of
investment decision future train
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could not
could potentially Mo lose all or more
than the initial investment risk capital
is money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
now you know I I do talk about um
you know just now I'm talking about
Janet Yellen I I I'm not a an economist
I don't claim to be an economist but you
know that's the market moving news and
you you got to be aware of of things
that can impact the market now yesterday
right you had the Trump Junior emails um
released by him that caused the market
to sell off you know that's not
something that you can predict oh you're
not going to predict that Donald Trump
junr is going to release his emails and
then and get a market reaction the way
he did um you know but today you do have
you know on the calendar Congressional
testimony from Janet Yellen it was
expected you know so Eyes Were Watching
that and you know as she's talking and
and saying stuff you know you could
parse it out and understand um you know
maybe you know she's not being as as
hawkish as she as you would expect and
you know that's why the market caught a
boost so you know you could I say
anticipate it
but you know it's not there it's not
catching you off guard okay now if she
come out and just if she said well I'm
going to hike one more time between now
and the end of um 2018 okay but you know
she's not really saying
anything
um Earth shattering you know she's got
uh you know basically her her interest
rate thoughts are know it's kind of
neutral right so it's not necessarily
encouraging um economic activity and
it's not discouraging economic activity
at the same time so um she wasn't very
hawkish and she was a bit on the dobish
side so anyway um again you know I don't
claim to be an economist but you know I
still look at the news and how it
affects the markets so you still have to
take that into account you know things
like the emails yesterday is totally
unexpected but you know things you know
coming into this day you know that you
got this and so you should be you know
attuned to you know sort of reading the
information as it's coming along you
don't have to watch your testimony or
anything but you know just you know
understand that that's what's moving the
market like yesterday when the market
sold off on the Trump emails everyone's
you know wondering around what the
going on why is this Market
selling off you know it's not till you
know a bit later that you know once
things calmed down and the market re you
know started rallying again that oh it
was get sold off because of this you
know back when I was you know in the
bank and you know stuff like that would
happen and you'd be getting calls from
you know everywhere the sales desk would
be calling you know the Traders hey
what's going on you and you know can it
be this can it be that yeah it can but
you know until all the dust is settled
and um
you know the market settled down that
you say yeah it was that but you know
now they got all these algo you know
these these hedge funds you know some of
them got these you know these Twitter
alos you know they they look for
keywords in in Twitter and things like
that and and trade around it but um but
anyway again you know I'm sort of ran
going on endlessly here I get back
to get back to uh orderflow um you know
the tools I use in this presentation are
orderflows Trader and the Delta scalper
so again you know equi big update so
we'll start in the equities
now uh let me get my 10 range S&P chart
here okay so you know again you know
7:30ish time the market started rallying
boom boom boom up and you know this is
10 range so you got very strong Deltas
no red bars and again you know it's how
do you know this move is strong
well you're one you're making new Highs
but two you know for me knowing that
this move move is is solid is look at
the Deltas okay and compare them to the
max Delta and the Min Delta okay in this
case since we're railing you should
really be comparing to the max Delta and
we are closing almost right on our Max
Delta so it's the strongest Delta in the
bar basically closing around so the
final Delta 4768 the max Delta was 4784
3604 I think that's 3604 6617 against
6623 7519 against
7525 4442 against 4901 so you know on
this move over this hour it's just all
very aggressive buying coming in you
know people's perception of the market
has changed you know yesterday we sold
off and we did rally back I did want to
see continuation today and we did get it
but although was due to different
circumstances but um you know that's how
you know this move is strong you know
you don't get you know Red Bar in here
with Divergence or anything we're
closing right on our Max Delta
number then you start getting up here
you hit hit this High you got a
Divergence no ratio um up here you got a
ratio no no Divergence cuz you still got
positive Delta but you know I remember I
was looking at you know around this time
here you know just before
10:00 watching this move up and then you
just sort of stall out in here and I
remember you know in the back of my head
and even the guys in the room I was
telling them say Hey you know this this
looks kind of bearish actually um you
know you're coming up here yeah you got
strong Delta 7,000 and you know only
4,000 but here you still going high but
now you got negative Delta then you know
on your high you got a strong negative
Delta this bar even though it's green
you got a negative Delta here you got
you know a bearish ratio um ratio bonds
low so there's there's some volume up
here on the on the top even though you
got um you know positive Delta why do
you have positive Delta is because you
got a lot of volume being transacted up
here on the offer on the high
2,000 which you know if if it was just
your normal high of like 500 you you'd
be looking at negative Delta but anyway
you know you can only trade what the
Market's telling you and right now it's
telling you you know you got positive
Delta but you know I could infer from it
you know I can look at the volume I mean
that's as your job as a Trader is to
analyze something you know something
doesn't necessarily
Jive in this in this case you know you
got heavy volume up here on the top you
got a ratio bonds low which indicates
heavy volume stopping
volume then you know put two and two
together okay so you know I I could
almost take it as a I don't say
synthetic Divergence but I I know that
we the reason we have positive Delta is
because there was Heavy selling up here
but you got again you're at highs so you
you got you know I don't say retail but
you got a lot of you know still buying
interest coming up into these Highs but
there's a big seller up here 2,000 okay
and it's causing the market to turn you
know it's holding I say causing it to
turn rather it's holding the market down
then you know so I could almost take it
a Divergence here but again I it's not
there it's not a real Divergence I'm
sort of you know extrapolating it but
you know then the next bar you got the
Delta scalper you've got um you know
again a bearish ratio and a strong
negative delt so at this time you know
I'm thinking hey this Market can can go
lower and then what happens nothing it
comes right back up here pretty quick
back down yeah at this point you jny
yelling speaking okay should you really
be taking any major trades no you know
if I was trading here it just be for
small size but again you know
it's you know there's certain there's
times of the month to trade times of the
month to just sit back and you know or
trade a different Market at this time um
you know that that's not going to be so
affected on you know what she's talking
about but anyway you had you taken the
trade again at this point I'm still kind
of bearish you know we're just hanging
around your highs you got these negative
Deltas you got bearish ratios you've got
you know selling and balance you got
Delta scalper but again it's starting to
alternate in here um you know red green
red then this bar is green so you know
when I start seeing you know red green
red you know alternating bars
alternating Deltas it's just a market
that's going sideways and we just
continue to go sideways you know here
you know we're not going anywhere your
point of control for the day on the
volume profile is just here you know
earlier it was like at 41 and a half you
know during during this time so now it's
you know it's you know we're start you
know we're just going we're not going
anywhere you know we're just going
sideways and it's already 11 o'clock so
from basically from you know 9:40 till
11:00 an hour and a half you're just you
know basically trading around 39 and a
half you know around in here so it's not
going anywhere you can see that you know
then comes up comes back down
again so you're just getting alternating
bars and you know the Market's just
going sideways as she's talking again
you comes down you get a red bar then
you get a green
bar now another green bar okay so what's
this next bar going to be it's going to
be another the Red Bar you're just going
to go sideways it's 12:00 she's
finishing talking but then here look at
this very strong Delta 6,000 which is
encouraging you know here you had 4,000
next bar was up then selling came in you
know but again you know we're a little
bit higher here closer to the highs
Janet Yellen is finished already and
then boom you hit the highs you got some
stacked imbalances but again you know at
this point it's like
we you know it's it's
1:00
okay you know do you still want to be in
this thingy can we go higher yeah we can
go higher I how much more are we going
to go higher 51 I think 51 and a half is
our is our lifetime High somewhere up
there I don't think we're going to get
there then you get this bar here just
for the cash close strong selling strong
negative Delta you know this move is
pretty much over for the day you know
we're going into the cash close you're
not seeing a lot of buying coming into
the cash close instead you're seeing
selling um and when you start seeing
selling coming in just ahead of the cash
close we're probably going to go a
little bit lower and we do um we get
another bar with strong negative
Delta and then we closed the day um you
know higher on the day which was good
but
um you know there really wasn't much
opportunity on the 10 range chart again
you I was looking for a bigger move down
here but again you got Janet Yellen
speaking so any moves you get going to
be kind of muted because you know no one
really wants to stick their neck out you
got the move earlier when you know when
her um statement came out you know
basically her say statement rather her
speech came
out and you know once she was talking
and qu I say question and answering but
um you know a lot of grandstanding by
these uh
politicians you know everyone's you know
you still got people coming out and
talking smack against Trump when you
know why why it's you know you should be
asking questions about the economy but
um anyway uh you know G to the four
range now there were some interesting
things here in the for range there was
one or two decent trades here so again
you know
7:30 boom you know that's when
the very you know that's when the buying
started happening you know boom all
aggressive buying buying imbalances on
the way up you get up here um you know
36 and a half you got a Divergence no
ratio you just kind of go sideways
sideways till the cash opens and start
riling
again you know Divergence here um you
get up here to this
High you got
a you got a Divergence you got a ratio
on the next bar which is to me is
bearish you know we we sell off a little
bit come back
up you know make sort of a halfway you
know half-hearted move down and sort of
come back up again um you
know excuse me got a bit of uh burping
but um yeah this is the thing okay so
you got your Divergence in your
ratio here you know should be getting
short in this bar you you know you make
a little poke lower come back up
again and you can't go lower here in
this bar than this previous low here
right you're still about a tick above so
that's that's not a good sign you know
if you're still short you know you
should be looking to cover it at you
know at a small loss or break even if
you can because you know the fact that
you started you know you rally back up
then you know you should get this move
it should happened here didn't came back
up it starts to make the move again and
it just can't get below this low of this
bar here that's not a good sign and what
happens is the market just sort of
gradually Works its way up then you get
to this bar here and make a new high
Divergence in a
ratio starts to come off this bar here
kind of I'll say worried me but you know
I don't like to get short then in the
bar I'm shorted all of a sudden turns
green and you got a bullish ratio but
what was nice to see was this bar here
this second bar after the high where'
you trade up to you traded right up to
the point of control so now your point
of control of this bar is is your
resistance you know I can feel pretty
safe on this one and then we start
trading down and you know where's your
point of control here where we trade we
trade right up to it this one one tick
below this one one tick below and you
make your move down here down to uh you
know 38 so this is a decent move from
you know 41 and a
half 41 and a half down to you know 38
and a half and then you just sort of go
around sideways sideways sideways you do
get some things you know here the
Stacked in
Balance I didn't think was that
interesting you know worthwhile trading
it would have been better to get a
little bit higher up I mean you just had
a move from your High um you know from
4275 down to 39 so almost a four-point
move 38 and
3/4 you know it would be better to get
it up here but you know whatever I I
just didn't think it was that
interesting at this point down
here then
here you
got oh okay sorry I just got interrupted
there um but anyway we came down to the
swing low here very strong positive
Delta Delta scalper also given a buy um
you know price rejector also given a buy
next bar three imbalance it's not
stacked imbalance but you know it's it's
three imbalances in a four range bar
which got five price levels so it's it's
quite strong you know there's some
buying coming in here already and we
start to Rally up slowly 11 12 you get
this swing High stacked uh sign balance
right afterwards but again I it's it's
at that point which is just right around
your point of control for the day so you
know I don't think it's going to be very
effective then a little bit later you
get three in a row right here 1 two
three um you don't get the entry that
I'd like I'd like to get an entry
between these two pointer controls you
it doesn't really happen I want it to
happen over the next two bars it doesn't
it still stays above it and then it just
sort of grinds its way higher higher
higher um you come out you take out the
highs stacked in Balance that's
encouraging but then you know we can't
go anywhere we just go a couple ticks
higher in the next bar at uh three and
3/4 at this High there's no uh no reason
to be selling honestly you got um I
think you point of control up near the
top you don't have a ratio don't have a
Divergence actually you do have a
Divergence just off the screen a little
bit um next bar it's just you know it's
still there it's still just sort of
hanging around that high you test the
high once
twice positive Delta so no Divergence
and then you start uh coming off um
before you close so you there was a
couple oh there there was one on the
four range chart that really stood out
that ratio and Divergence um you know
that was that was really the the best
trading opportunity of the day in the
PS um let me take a look at uh I'll talk
about bonds really quick Bond was a nice
trade uh I I pointed out in the trading
room this morning and what it was is
after again you know this Market really
moved after
uh Janet Yellen
uh came out and released her notes for
what she was going to talk about uh
during her testimony which is standard
um you then later around 8:42 just for
845 you got this bar so you had your
high here okay at uh just after 8:00 you
don't got uh ratio you don't have a
Divergence but you start you sell off a
little bit you know a couple ticks uh
over the next couple bars some new lows
then you start coming back up here and
you're making a run at this high and you
got this buying imbalance here okay so
you think through think through what's
happening Market sells off or hits the
high starts coming off a little bit you
know nothing dramatic IC you know no big
down downward moves instead you know we
this bar it opens down here sells off
the tick rallies up and then sells off
this bar we open on our low rally up and
then here you get buyers coming you got
this imbalance right
here and it goes one tick higher and it
can't hit that high all of a sudden all
these people that are buying it looking
for this breakout realize it's not
coming in and then boom you know the
market sells off and it sells off pretty
quick there's three lot trade here 285
which is not much and obviously zero
here we formed the new bar and then we
just you know had lower I was looking
for a move down to 24 which we got
pretty quick you know this is at 28 29
in here um and we made the move down
below 24 here this to me this was again
I I pointed that out to everybody in the
room um that that was you know as it was
forming
here U but then we hit this bar here you
know I I gave a webinar the other day
and I talked about specifically this
point of control at the extremes and you
also have a a bullish ratio it's a ratio
BS low indicating stopping volume volume
and we Rally from you know the 22 23
area all the way back up to 153 so there
was two nice you know opportunities here
in in the bonds you know on the move
down and the move back up
there okay really quick in the crude
very similar to um what I explained in
the bonds you know Point control at the
extreme you have this move up from your
low um in the crude from you know your
low of 45 38 you rally up to uh 78 point
of control at the extreme you have a
ratio bonds low you have this red arrow
indicating you know Traders are stuck up
here and what happens you know the
market sells off now in the bonds you
didn't have the the Green Arrow because
it was a Buy in this one you do have a
red arrow which gives you know also you
know puts additional oomph into the
trade but again you know I I talk about
these things you don't need you know
some fancy software to look you know at
the point of control in the bar you
should see it it sticks out you know
really really fast you know if if
uh where's the NASDAQ here a good
example is is NASDAQ right um I I don't
remember if there was any extreme point
of controls but you know extreme point
of controls on on markets like NASDAQ
markets that move around pretty quick
are usually pretty darn effective um
let's just sort of go back
here uh take it back cash opening
time I I don't think there was but again
you know reading what's going on in the
order flow Point control right near the
bottom in this case you got some heavy
volume uh 289 485 there we we shoot up
uh we do come off
later it's not on the
low and I don't remember seeing any but
anyway I'll just go through it see if
there was any or not you know you got
some nice signals here Delta scalper
gives a buy there
um you know Delta scoper gives a sell
there comes right back with the buy
here really what I'm looking for is just
on the extreme now I'm not interested
you know on a green bar with at the top
a green bar want it on the bottom a red
bar want it on the top not on the
bottom I mean it doesn't take rocket
science to see that but in then the the
the I'll say the logic behind it but you
know why it happens because there's
volume there stopping the move it's
nothing fancy you know I don't need to
analyze the price over x amount of bars
or anything like that you know and con
and you know mix it up in some
mathematical equation no you know it's
the market generated information telling
you what's uh what's
happening no I mean usually in the
NASDAQ you're good for one or two a day
um there wasn't anything
today any that's the close um the last
part I got to talk about about is the
Yen really
quick well no I'll talk about soybeans
real quick soybeans was was a nice
Market soybeans are a great Market to
trade you know it doesn't get the
respect as uh you know the financial
products you know what do you do I'm a
bean Trader do what are you a farmer no
but you know beans grains follow
overflow really beautifully you know
it's it's something you don't have a lot
uh well now today you had the uh
USDA numbers come out but you know it's
it's not a market
that that um you know follows you know
the the hot money you know the retail
money coming in out it's it's something
that really is you know is driven
by mostly I say mostly but there's a lot
of institutional playing and so you got
a lot of uh supply and demand at work
and that's where order flow is really
going to help you out so okay
8:30 will is is the reopen here and you
know you start going off now you had
USDA numbers coming coming out today at
11 so you got to be careful um so you
know 9:00 you got a ratio sorry you got
Divergence in a ratio you see the market
comes off a few cents R back up same
thing Divergence in a ratio Market goes
sideways okay you know it didn't uh you
know wasn't a great trade um then here
you get it again you know 10:30 now be
careful because you know 11:00 fireworks
are going to happen um you got the
Divergence and a ratio afterwards here
on this
high and then you sell off then you know
11:00 if you're in a position um
definitely be out of it when uh when the
reports come out in in
grains and again you I don't want to get
into what the numbers were but
uh you know the
the demand the production I think was
was projected at
4.2 million bushels
um but the yield forecast was unchanged
again I don't really care what these
numbers came out at um again I'm just
trying to go off my memory here but but
anyway you know 11:00 is when all the
the fireworks happen that's why you see
all these weird looking bars cuz you
know one ninja Trader can't keep up with
the data as it as it's being released
and two it's it's there's just no
liquidity in there so you know there's
trading going on but I'm not really
interested in it I'm waiting for the
market to settle down I mean there's
nobody saying you have to trade it right
now because the number came out no you
know people that trade during numbers
are generally retail Traders the big
money stays aside they wait for the
settle down and then they start trading
again
um okay but again you know here swing
high point of control right at the
extreme you know it's 11:44 it's 45
minutes after the number came out it's a
nice sell and then you know it's backed
up with uh the price sorry the Delta
scalper right afterwards again you know
I I talked about this in my webinar the
other day um and again you don't need a
fancy trading tool to say hey point of
control is at the top I mean yeah I
could code it actually I do have it
coded um but but again you know I'm
saying you know if you're not using my
software you're using something else I
think you know my software is better but
you know I do have something that can
draw a line there like this Aqua
line and then you know Delta scalper giv
a sell boom and you know from 1034 uh
just shoots down down down down to 10 um
you know I don't know how low it got
here and this yeah well anyway you got
your your next Delta scalper by here at
1028 so that's already 6 cents you know
that's a nice move that's like six
points in the S&P
you know then you get down here at the
swing low you got to buy with the Delta
scalper and it goes back up from you
know 1025 a half all the way back up to
you know the 10 29 29 30 area up in here
so you know there's some nice nice
trades there in the S&P H sorry snps
soybeans and the last one I'll talk
about is uh
japen if I can find my
charts and it's just a
classic Divergence and ratio you know
759 and you get a nice move from you
know the
8778 area right on down to you know 87
you know 68 so you know it's it's 20
ticks in the in the gfn it's you know
it's half tick so it's 20 10 full ticks
20 half ticks but you know these are the
moves that happen you know every day you
know I I talk about them you know every
day like it's you know something new but
it's not you know you see these same
markets exhibiting the same things day
in day out you know I mean if if really
if you're not using orderflow you're
really I think leaving a lot on the
table but anyway you know I drink the
Kool-Aid why because you know it's what
I've been using for many years and and I
know it's good I know it's um you know
helped a lot of people in their trading
and you'd be kind of uh I say nuts but
you'd be you'd really be leaving a lot
of uh nice trading opportunities out
there if you're just using you know a
normal bar chart and using price based
indicators which I mean learn to trade
you know learn to read what the Market's
telling you rather than just oh we're
crossing this uh you know moving average
is crossing this moving average know
that's what not moves the market that's
not what moves markets that's not how
the market reacts you know people don't
sit back and and say oh well you know
we're crossing this moving average you
know let's all get short no you know I
said you know I've worked in banks for
over 10 years I've worked for commodity
trading firms for over 5 years and you
know I I've yet to meet someone sits
there you know especially intraday
traders that you know got all these
fancy you know I'll say fancy I don't
want to use the term fancy indicators
but use you know macd RSI you know I
don't to say I haven't met anybody I've
probably met probably a handful I can
count on one hand and actually the
people that I met that use that have
those on their screen they're using it
because they know how people react there
and they'll just go in and and whack
them you know because they know there's
going to be liquidity at those areas so
you know they'll they'll either fade it
or you know get it going in in the
direction short term to get the move
happening so all these idiots say oh
look you know MCD has picked this
turning point and then all of a sudden
it stops and then you know Market goes
up in the other direction
so you know our are big Traders using
technical indicators yeah they are but
you know they're they're not using it in
the sense to to help you they're using
it you know against you because they
know how the the mass you know the use
the term sheep but you know how about
the retail Traders look at these
technical indicators and um react to
them so anyway again you know it's up to
you if you want to use overflow if
you're not using it I really think you
know you're you're really leaving a lot
on the table you know ask yourself as a
Trader are you trading to the best of
your abilities you know if you think
well I found the perfect combination of
indicators good luck to you good luck to
you godspeed but I'll be honest with you
you know these um you know this stuff's
been mined to death you know with you
know trade station came up you know even
system writer back in the early 90s
trade station in the 90s you know people
were running you know all these
permutations of different com
combinations of um indicators try to
find the right ones that work you know
so if all you think you're coming in
here 20 30 years later going to find the
Holy Grail like good luck to you I mean
you might but you know the odds are
really really against you but you know
if you really want to learn how the
market trades how the market moves then
you should you know understand order
flow and understand what you're seeing
in the market Market as it's happening
so thanks for watching this video be
sure to subscribe to my channel and
thanks everybody
bye-bye